the future of Hollywood powerhouse The
Weinstein Company is uncertain this
morning the board fired co-founder
Harvey Weinstein last night following
the revelation of sexual harassment
allegations that stretch back decades
New York Times correspondent and CBS
News contributor Jody canter spoke spent
rather four months investigating the
story with her colleague Megan to a
joint Jody joins us once again at the
table Jody been a very busy weekend for
those of us following the Harvey
Weinstein story in for Harvey Weinstein
himself probably more busy for Judy yes
exactly right
was there a final straw that finally led
to the firing yesterday it was announced
last night that Harvey Weinstein was
fired effective immediately the board
says that they're continuing to learn
about allegations about what Harvey
Weinstein may have done to women and I
think his firing by the way it does not
really end that question I think the
question we all face now is what was the
size and scope of this thing what really
happened in this situation how come this
behavior appears to have continued for
decades did anybody including the board
of The Weinstein Company try to stop it
well that's what I'm curious about if it
had been going on for decades why is it
that the board didn't know that it was
allegedly an open secret in Hollywood
you know my colleague Megan chewy has
been investigated in that investigating
that question very very hard one answer
to the question is legal settlements we
do know for sure that Harvey Weinstein
had women who complained of allegations
of sexual harassment not only signed
settlements but signed confidentiality
agreements saying that they would not
agree the board acknowledged that they
knew about those settlements and I had
to know about the settlement because it
would be paid out of I think the
question of what exactly the board knew
and when they knew it is something we're
looking at very very closely you're at
the center of this I mean tell us what
it's like to be a reporter
you know that's written a story that's
an ongoing story I assume people calling
you I'm assumed that everybody you know
once this is has its own momentum well I
think what we feel is the responsibility
of getting this right and understanding
what
happened this was a situation in which
there were silence for so long there was
a heavy intimidation factor mr.
Weinstein was an incredibly powerful
figure in a Hollywood and so I think
what we're devoted to is really
understanding the issues here just how
big this was and how it played out and
who may have been hurt in the process
his attorneys told us last week quote we
sent the times the facts and evidence
but they ignored it and rushed to
publish did Weinstein or his lawyers
provide you with facts and evidence to
discredit the claim they knew about our
story well ahead of time we have been
working on it all summer with their
knowledge we asked them plenty of
questions in advance at the end of the
process we came to them with very
specific allegations they had 48 hours
to respond and we stand by the facts and
the fairness of our reporting was his
fate predetermined by the time you had
published this article I mean it had he
been more contrite in the fall in the
aftermath do you think that he could
have survived or no you know his
response was fascinating because if
there was like a piano where denial was
here an apology was here he plead every
key in between and he kept switching and
I'm not sure we've heard him settle on a
final answer there have been so many
famous women who have praised him from
the stage while thinking you know I want
to thank Harvey Weinstein I think a lot
of people knew Harvey to be very
passionate about his movies and
relentless and trying to get warts for
his movies and his actresses that's why
I'm so confused to hear or surprised to
hear this was such an open secret that
so many people know that this was going
on I think the question stands who
protected Harvey Weinstein who protected
the women did the women feel they could
speak up did they feel that anybody
would believe them did they fear that
this would hurt their careers and forget
the Obamas daughter even interned for
them as recently as this past summer so
many more questions to be asked a
wonderful reporting Jody thing yeah well
if the Obamas had suspected this they
never would be exactly I don't imagine
they're asking all the same questions I
would imagine so too